مراكز الايواء هي الاكثر تضررا من جراء
هذه الاحوال الجويه السيئه من المتوقع
ايضا ان تكون هناك احوال جويه سيئه خلال
الايام القادمه هذه الاماكن التي يتواجد
فيها النازحون من شمال قطاع غزه ومن مدينه
غزه وبالتالي هذه الخيام هي فقط ماواهم
خلال هذه الامطار اثار هذه الامطار على
الارض الرياح والملابس حتى التي يلبسونها
هي ملابس خفيفه لانهم جاؤوا بلا ش من
مناطق النزوح من منازلهم في مدينه غزه
وشمال قطاع غزه هذه هي الغرفه التي تعيش
فيها هذه العائله اطفال صغار اطفال من
مختلف الاعمار وجميعهم في هذه الغرفه
الصغيره ربما الصوره يعني ابلغ من اي كلام
عن هذه الاوضاع في ظل هذه هذا البرد
القارس وهذا الشتاء الذي يعانون فيه من كل
شيء حمد على سلامتكم الله يسلمك كيف انتم
عايشين هنا زي ما انتم شايفين لا في وسع
في المدرسه ولا في حاجه وفيش غرف وانا
اولادي هيني قاعد في هذ الخيمه وكلها مطر
وسقعه ولا ظروف الاكل عندنا صعبه كثير حتى
الخبز نن على الصاج بنعمله وبصعوبه يعني
لا في حطب ولا في اي حاجه وحتى اولادنا
كلهم مرضوا والله كل اولادي مرضوا من
السقعه ومن البرد وسبتهم يعني من المدرسه
وبا ومرض ويعني ايش بدي اقول لك حياتنا
صعبه كثير والله يعني سبنا بيوتنا ما فيش
في الراء اولادنا مرض اولادنا مرضانين كنا
مرضانين الكبار مرضانين الميه ملوثه كل
غزه مريضين كل الشعب مريض المساحه هذه في
المعتاد بقى 3000 يسكن الاواء اليوم 10
الا ساكن في الاواء هذا لما بتجيبوا
المساعدات ايش بتكفي يعني كل واحد علبه
فول 20 نفر ولا 15 نفر ايش بتعمل انتقلنا
الى هنا الى دير البلح وسط قطاع غزه وهذه
صوره اخرى من المعاناه التي يعانيها سكان
القطاع جراء هذه الحرب الاسرائيليه وجراء
منع دخول الوقود والغاز هذه واحده من اكبر
المحطات لتعبئه الغاز الطبيعي الناس
يتجمعون هنا منذ اكثر من اربعه ايام وهم
يحاولون الحصول على انبوبه من الغاز من
اجل التخلص من الطبخ وقد اعتاد الناس خلال
هذه الحرب الطبخ على النار لكن الان هم
يحاولون الحصول على هذه الانابيب وتعبئه
هذه الانابيب من الغاز لا سما مع دخول
الغاز الطبيعي الى داخل قطاع غزه من بعد
دخول التهدئه المؤقته حيز التنفيذ الحمد
لله على السلامه يا حج الله يسلمك يا ابوي
الله يسعدك ايش بتستنى ومن وقت ايش بتستنى
انا الي من اول امبارح من اول امبارح نمت
هنا على اساس استنى على اساس اعبي اللي هي
جره غاز 12 كيلو ولحتى اللحظه يعني بقول
لك بننتظر يعني احنا ان شاء الله وانتظار
صعب بنتظر انه قالوا الساعه 12 الساعه حده
صل الغاز ع ن عبه احنا
عايشين عايشين بلملم الحطب عشان نعمل طبخه
يعني وعند الناس ما فهمت لانه احنا على
المساعدات فاحنا الغاز مهم لنا في عننا
اطفال بدها تشرب حليب في عننا نساء حاملات
في يعني مش عيشه هذه بعدين يمكن ما فيش 40
يوم ننا بنشتغل على الحطب بس اذا هذه هي
صوره من صور المعاناه التي يعانيها سكان
قطاع غزه جراء هذه الحرب المدمره وجراء
نقص المواد التموينيه والغذائيه وا ايضا
جراء نقص الوقود والغاز هشام زقو الجزيره
من دير البلح وسط قطاع غزه فلسطين